I sat down with your insurance agency
the sponsors of this next segment to
discuss why Healthcare reviews are vital
for all ages
it's that time of year again we are back
at your insurance agency thanks for
having us Chris now usually when we talk
about health insurance you think older
adults but really it's vital for all
ages right it's important for all ages
because we don't know when life's going
to happen and that's why an open
enrollment is so important to pay
attention to now why is open enrollment
annual
for several reasons but one is that
that's when plans change deductibles
doctors out of pocket premiums and so on
but also that is the most important time
of year to enroll because if you don't
enroll you lose the opportunity to get
insurance for the rest of the year and
we don't know what's going to happen
that's so true now if you like your
current plan why is it still important
to seek coverage
well things have changed there's tax
credits there's could change it could be
benefits change benefits change plans
change new carriers come in the market
you need to revisit you have to look at
your income because it could be
resources out there to help get more
lower costs and benefits but also get
more Health paying for premiums you just
don't know and so it's very important to
do revisits your policies every year and
revisiting policies every year that's
why you guys are here to help us do that
what's something that people should be
prepared for what should they bring when
they come to see you you know bring your
taxes your tax forms so we can look at
that we bring your your driver's license
your IDs your doctors your medications
all those things that will help us get
you the best plan that's suitable to
your needs there's many resources to get
insurance we all know there's the
internet we all know there's places you
can call 1-800 numbers you got to
realize though a lot of those places are
just selling one product or one carrier
and now you're very limited when you're
working with a broker such as us we
represent many plans many carriers so we
can then help you discover what's best
for you now what are some things people
should consider when choosing their plan
so some of the concerns we run into what
people need to be concerned about is as
we become retirees what am I going to do
I'm going to stay here in Nevada or do I
want to travel so we need a plan that's
going to be portable if we want to
travel
and or if you have children that get
ready to go to college do we have a plan
that's going to work in Nevada and is it
going to work where they're going to
school so you have those are a couple
things to consider but also what other
benefits you're looking for such as
Dental hearing Vision gym memberships
all those other things that may be
important that you need to address
another thing to consider are our
penalties and consequences right correct
so one of the things that you need to do
annually is to do a checkup because if
you don't do things at the right time
there are certain ages in life that we
hit so certain benchmarks where you
cannot continue your current plan and if
you keep your current plan you could
have consequences possibly paying back
tax credits you weren't entitled to or
penalties that you would have to pay for
the rest of your life by staying on the
wrong plan
thank you your insurance agency for
sponsoring that segment you can find
them at the Meadows Mall for more just
call
702-425-5500 or visit yianv.com